[Music]
George Clooney has his AFI tribute which
airs tonight on TNT and you know what so
many famous faces are expressing their
love for the ass corner but only one
does George's partner for life he is the
person who has my complete admiration
and also the person whose smile makes me
melt my love what I have found with you
is the great love that I always hoped
existed and seeing you with our children
Allen Alexander is the greatest joy in
my life
you can cue the Oz as a mob gives an
emotional seven-minute speech all about
her man a couple of confessions she
can't sleep when they're apart George
also hides love letters in her bag
how proud are you of your hubby tonight
very very proud
we met started hiding out in my London
flat and very soon it felt like no
matter what happened I would never want
to be with anyone else but Amal isn't
the only woman swooning over George
I still get stopped in the street every
day by people who want to know what it's
like to work with George Clooney yes
he's a good kisser I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
we were good together we could finish
each other's sentences
lucky I got very very nice way to put it
I thought you couldn't have it all I
thought if you had a successful career
that you weren't really gonna be able to
have one great love in your life and
then the mall walked in there you
roasted a little bit too I find my rows
that I'd be shocked with you a little
bit if you're an actor this is one of
the great things that could ever happen
to you so it's really fun it's fun to be
here
[Music]